Voici la première vidéo d'une série de Cyrusly un peu spéciaux.
L'idée dans les prochains mois, c'est de vous donner les clés en à peu près 5 minutes,
des programmes des differents candidats à l'élection présidentielle pour que vous puissiez y voir plus clair.
Alors je sais ce que vous allez me dire :
"Ouais, mais Cyrus, ça sert à rien ce que tu fais
tous les programmes sont disponibles en ligne,
de toute façon on peut très bien les lire tout seul..."
Ce à quoi je répondrai : "déjà encore une fois, personne ne parle comme ça,
et en plus les programmes des politiques en lignes, bah c'est un petit peu comme
les mises à jours des conditions générales de snapchat :
tout le monde y a accès, tout le monde sait que c'est hyper important,
mais personne ne les lit !
Je vais donc essayer de vous résumer ces programmes sans porter de jugement,
en me concentrant sur ce que chaque candidat souhaite mettre en avant dans son programme.
L'idée c'est de garder à peu près la même structure entre chaque vidéo,
et malgré tout, je vous encourage chaudement à vous renseigner par vous même,
et à aller consulter les différents programmes des candidats, ce n'est que comme ça que vous pourrez avoir en tête
l'intégralité de leurs propositions (propositions que je ne pourrai malheureusement pas couvrir en 5 minutes)
et c'est très important pour pouvoir prendre une décision d'avoir toutes les informations.
Enfin dernière chose : on ne parlera pas non plus des différents scandales qui peuvent être liés à chaque candidat.
D'autres le feront beaucoup mieux que moi, donc j'ai décidé de me concentrer sur le programme uniquement.
Et puisqu'on parle de prises de décisions et qu'il faut bien commencer par quelqu'un,
on va parler du programme d'un homme qui a décidé que la France n'avait plus le temps pour l'indécision : François Fillon.
Son programme c'est de redresser la France, lui redonner sa puissance, redorer son blason
et pour ça il faut commencer par avoir une France compétitive face aux autres pays en libérant l'économie.
Avec Fillon, ça commence par une baisse des dépenses publiques de 100 milliards en 5 ans, justement pour redresser le pays.
Alors comment on arrive à économiser 100 milliards?
Et bien, il a plusieurs pistes : rétablir les 39 heures dans la fonction publique, plafonner et rendre dégressives les allocations chômage
et traquer via des audits, ce qui coûte cher et ne sert à rien pour le supprimer ou le remplacer par des actions en lesquelles il croit plus.
Il propose aussi 40 milliards de baisse des charges pour les entreprises pour créer un 'big bang' de l'emploi
et 10 milliards d'allègements sociaux et fiscaux pour les ménages afin de dynamiser l'économie,
quitte à les financer partiellement par une hausse de la TVA, et veut globalement supprimer tout ce qui empêche le privé de s'épanouir.
Et il y a un tas d'autres mesures qui sont dans le but de libérer cette économie,
comme supprimer les 35h pour rendre le travailleur français plus compétitif,
instaurer un contrat de travail avec des modalités de ruptures prédéfinies pour plus de flexibilité
et supprimer l'ISF (--> Impôt sur la fortune) pour encourager la réussite et le financement des entreprises par des gens aujourd'hui taxés.
Après, en partant du constat que nous vivons de plus en plus âgés,
il propose le recul de l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans et l'unification de tous les régimes de retraite.
L'idée étant qu'on travail plus longtemps et cotisons plus pour maintenir un meilleur pouvoir d'achat.
Dans cette même logique de redorer le blason de la France, on retrouve un set de valeurs de la République française :
il souhaite soutenir et promouvoir une politique familiale forte en rétablissant l'universalité des allocations,
il ne touchera pas à la loi Taubira (2013, Mariage pour tous), sauf sur la question de l'adoption, la PMA, Procréation médicalement assistée,
qui ne doit être reversée qu'aux couples hétérosexuels infertiles et la GPA (Gestation pour autrui), qui doit être interdite.
Quitte à repositionner la France au niveau international, il propose de positionner la France en chef de fil au niveau mondial
sur la lutte contre la marchandisation du corps de la femme car "payer une femme pour qu'elle porte un enfant pour autrui m'est intolérable", je cite.
La laïcité est aussi pour François Fillon l'une des valeurs les plus importantes de la république
et selon lui, elle a été mise à mal ces dernières années.
Il souhaite donc la restaurer en permettant aux entreprises d'imposer un code de laïcité à leurs salariés,
rendre le financement de l'Islam transparent et sanctionner les prêches anti-français et les discours favorables à la Charia et au Djihad.
Toujours avec cette idée de rendre la France compétitive et de lui redonner sa position de superpuissance mondiale,
François Fillon est pro-nucléaire et souhaite consolider la filière, seule énergie permettant selon lui,
aujourd'hui, aux Français une indépendance énergétique à un prix abordable.
Il souhaite aussi prouver qu'il est possible d'associer économie et écologie en développant
une filière française des énergies renouvelables pour faire de la France un champion du secteur.
Il ajoute à cela cependant son souhait de protéger les espaces naturels de la France
et d'obtenir des résultats en matière d'amélioration de la qualité de l'air.
Car, même si, pour la journaliste Ruth Elkrief , l'écologie  semble être une question de "bobos"!
La pollution atmosphérique reste la troisième cause de mortalité en France.
Redonner à la France sa puissance, cela passe aussi par restaurer l'autorité de l'Etat.
et là, on la le droit de dépenser un peu d'argent!
On n'est plus là pour déconner, c'est tolérance zéro.
Il prévoit donc d'investir jusqu'à 2% du PIB à l'horizon 2025 pour améliorer la condition des militaires.
D'investir 12 milliards d'euros;  dans la sécurité, la défense et la justice.
En créant au passage 16 000 places de prison en plus ,
pour que les peines puissent enfin être purgées.
Avec les terroristes même combat,
on interdit le retour, sur le territoire, aux français parti combattre avec les terroristes à l'étranger.
et on expulse de France toute mouvance qui s'en approche.
Tolérance zéro! et comme il n'y a pas de petite réforme sécuritaire.
On supprime les allocations aux familles, dont les enfants commettent des manquements répétés.
on sanctionne désormais systématiquement, toutes les infractions qui pourrissent la vie des français,
et on accepte les uniformes dans les établissements qui le souhaitent.
C'est la même chose. Tolérance zéro!
j'arrête mais vous avez l'idée. François Fillon n'est pas homme à sourciller.
On met donc un terme à l'immigration irrégulière en expulsant tous les clandestins
et on réduit l'immigration légale à son strict minimum.
Cela passe par l'instauration de quotas annuels d'immigration,
la réforme de la procédure d'asile et du regroupement familiale
et la mise en place de statistiques ethniques
et faire désormais de l'assimilation, la condition sine qua non à la nationalité française.
Donc, retour au valeurs, restauration de l'autorité de l'Etat et libération de l'économie.
vous connaissez maintenant la formule de François Fillon pour redresser la France.
et les grandes lignes de son programme pour 2017.
Je vous mets dans la description un lien avec son programme complet.
Pour que vous puissiez allez plus loin, par vous même.  On se retrouve très vite pour le prochain candidat!
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu!  5mn c'est très court, ça demande d'être très synthétique.
Mais le but ici ce n'est peut-être pas de toucher les gens qui s'intéresse à la politique d'habitude.
Mais plutôt les autres; ceux qui s'en sont désintéressé
et à vous, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a rendues les choses un  peu plus claires.
je vous invite à me suivre sur Facebook, Twitter et Snapchat
N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo et à vous abonnez pour ne pas rater les prochaines !
Un gros merci aux tipeurs  qui participent à cette mission public
Love!  Peace!  ciao!